la vie du monde je vous le disais en
commençant cette antenne de midi c'est
l'histoire de la vie sur terre que nous
allons essayer de retracer aujourd'hui
grâce à une exposition organisée au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle par le CNS
le CNRS voilà on y arrive le Muséum
d'histoire naturelle c'est amusé pierre
Champetier qui est bien oublier du grand
public oui je suis actuellement au
Jardin des Plantes c'est un jardin qui
est bien connu des Parisiens puisqu'il y
viennent ils promener les enfants le
dimanche et dernièrement c'est la
galerie de zoologie là c'est un endroit
très mystérieux puisqu'il est fermé au
public depuis de longues années je vous
propose d'entrer avec moi dans cette
galerie de monter quelques marches et
d'entrer dans la partie la plus secrète
du Muséum là où personne ne connaît
jamais
alors ça c'est une porte qui ne chauffe
pas souvent pratiquement jamais quelques
rares fois chaque année lors de la
cuisine de chercheurs étrangers de
savants étrangers qui n'ont pas chez eux
les trésors que nous avons ici c'est le
coffre-fort de la maison ça c'est
malheureusement l'endroit où nous avons
regroupé plusieurs centaines d'espèces
qui sont soit totalement disparus soit
en voie de disparition immédiate
celui-ci par exemple qu'est-ce que c'est
bien celui-ci par exemple c'est un
thilassine où marsupial ou encore tigre
de Tasmanie qui n'existe plus
officiellement depuis 1933 sur ce que la
dernière capture a été réalisée à cette
date comment il a disparu et bien il a
disparu parce que il a été considéré
comme un dévoreur de moutons ce qui
génère les populations qui se sont
installées là-bas et à une certaine
époque il y a environ un siècle on
payait les gens pour le détruire et
depuis quelques dizaines d'années tout
au contraire
les gens qui sont en possession d'une
dépouille de ce loup marsupial sont au
contraire condamnés à 20 ans de prison
ça c'est le dodo le fameux dodo c'est
une reconstitution c'est une
reconstitution qui a été rendue possible
par
leur récolte de reste
osseux de ce gros pigeon qui est
originaire de l'île Maurice et qui était
connu au 16e siècle il a disparu il a
disparu nous sommes certains qu'au 17e
siècle il n'existait plus
il s'agit cette fois-ci du dernier loup
qui a été tué en France puisque il a été
tué le 5 juin 1968 dans le département
des Landes il est infiniment probable
que ses parents s'étaient installés dans
les Landes venant d'Espagne plusieurs
années auparavant et lorsque les jeunes
vers l'âge de deux ans ce sont séparés
des parents ils se sont trouvés dans
l'obligation de chasser eux-mêmes et ont
trouvé beaucoup plus facile de
s'attaquer aux moutons qu'au gibier
sauvage
d'où les dégâts qu'ils ont commis et par
conséquent la chasse dont ils ont été
l'objet
il va de soi que ce qui est contenu dans
cette salle constitue un trésor tout à
fait inestimable mais je n'ai qu'une
crainte en somme je crains très
sincèrement que de nombreux spécimens
qui se trouvent dans la galerie à côté
ne viennent un jour ici dans ce
cimetière des espèces éteintes ça veut
dire qu'il y aurait encore une espèce
disparue
bien entendu il faut savoir que les
espèces disparaissent à un rythme
beaucoup plus rapide qu'on ne le croit
généralement surtout dans le domaine des
oiseaux et nous n'avons aucune envie en
ce qui nous concerne d'augmenter la
population de ce cimetière je vous
propose maintenant de sortir du
coffre-fort on se retourne et voilà ce
qu'on découvre c'est un spectacle
fantastique une immense salle grande
comme un hall de gare plongé dans
l'obscurité et le silence et des
milliers d'animaux empaillés comme figés
dans l'éternité et couvert de poussière
il y en a ici plus de 5 millions presque
tous les animaux que la terre apportés
aux portent encore ils ont été entassés
ici par des générations de chasseurs et
de naturaliste c'est un spectacle
absolument fascinant Square est dans un
immense cimetière et pourtant nous
sommes en présence de la plus importante
et de la plus riche collection
zoologique du monde
depuis 15 ans elle est fermée au public
petit à petit elle s'est enfoncée dans
l'oubli et la poussière victime du temps
du manque de crédit et la désaffection
du public en 1889 quand cette galerie de
zoologie a été inaugurée il y avait à
peine une centaine d'animaux dans
l'aménagerie le cinéma n'existait pas
encore le Muséum était pratiquement le
seul moyen de découvrir toutes les
richesses de la nature et du monde
animal car ici tout le règne animal est
représenté à quelques unités près un
million 150 000 espèces au total pour
satisfaire la curiosité du public et des
savants à l'époque qu'on ne lésinait pas
sur les moyens impossible par exemple
d'imaginer ce qu'a pu coûter la
naturalisation de tous ces animaux et
puis peu à peu les goûts ont changé en
même temps la galerie de zoologie faute
d'entretien a commencé à se dégrader le
chauffage fait craquer l'épaule le
soleil décolore les fourrures en 1944
c'est la verrière qui crève et la pluie
qui tourne à l'intérieur en 1965 il faut
fermer au public un tiers de la
collection et détruite à force d'alerter
les pouvoirs publics sur la
pertinestimable représente ce trésor
scientifique les responsables du Muséum
au bout de 15 ans négociations
obtiennent enfin des crédits il faudra
environ 10 milliards de centimes pour
réouvrir la salle les travaux vont
commencer dans quelques mois c'est une
grosse opération monsieur Doors comment
allez-vous procéder certainement c'est
une grande opération la première étape
sera de construire ici même dans
l'endroit où nous nous trouvons
d'aménager un gigantesque trou dans
lequel nous allons construire ce que
nous avons appelé une zootech
c'est-à-dire un endroit où seront
conservés précisément tous ces spécimens
d'intérêt scientifique mais dans un
premier temps bien sûr cela servira de
Havre pour tous les animaux que nous
allons vider nous allons évacuer
entièrement la galerie de zoologie de
manière à la livrée aux architectes et
aux entrepreneurs en vue des travaux de
modernisation et ensuite vous remettrez
les animaux vous les remettrez tous nous
les remettrons bien sûr pas tous il y a
des collections scientifiques qui n'ont
qu'un intérêt que pour le spécialiste et
au contraire nous remettrons après
réflexion tous les spécimens qui
présentent un intérêt pour le public
d'un point de vue pédagogique au point
de vue démonstration ça va coûter
beaucoup d'argent est-ce que vous croyez
vraiment que ça vaut la peine de
restaurer cette salle et tous ces
animaux alors que les gens ne vont
presque plus au zoo est-ce que vous
croyez que le public va revenir ici et
que le Muséum va reprendre un nouveau
départ bien c'est une question que nous
sommes posés à priori et nous y
répondons résolument par une manière
positive car ce que un musée peut
apporter à l'heure actuelle des réponses
à deux questions principales la première
c'est pourquoi c'est diversité d'animaux
commencent c'est fait l'évolution pour
ça il faut pas conséquent que par des
panneaux que par des démonstrations on
montre au public le lien parce que le
but de l'évolution et la deuxième raison
et la deuxième raison c'est évidemment
l'écologie on ne montre plus des animaux
isolés on montre des groupes d'animaux
de manière à précisément préciser quels
sont leurs relations et comment se
constitue cette espèce de trame de la
vie donc l'optique est totalement
différente à l'heure actuelle nous
voulons centrer cela sur l'écologie sur
la trame véritablement de la vie bien
écoutez il pleut ici je crois qu'il vaut
mieux vous rendre l'antenne